seems pretty unassuming just a dude in a
thick coat walking to well wherever it
is that dudes and thick coats walk to
however this man is the single most
dangerous person in the entire hunter
hunter world more evil than ceradnik
more driven than netaro and potentially
even more powerful than meruem this
man's name is gyro and he is going to
destroy the world meanwhile my name is
liam and i'm not going to do that
because i quite like the world although
to be fair if i'd had gyro's upbringing
then i can't guarantee what i do gyro is
a confusing character in the hunt hunt
fandom mostly because depending on
whether you've watched the anime or read
the manga those are two completely
different experiences of him if you
watch the anime then quite honestly gyro
could be a very forgettable character
his name gets mentioned a bunch like
quite a few times actually but by the
time we even really realize he exists
he's been killed and fed to the ant
queen so he kind of fizzles out and his
whole existence feels like a story that
was never quite completed whereas in the
manga not only is that story complete
but it also completely changes the way
that you will see gyro and even gone
gyro and gone are characters who are
intrinsically linked and not just
because of all of the nice fluffy
narrative parallels that we can make
between them but because the narrator of
the series quite literally said so and
if there is any good reason to bring
gone back into the story this this is it
because these two have unfinished
business and the sheer amount of
information that was left out of the tv
series is going to shock anime watchers
also this video is sponsored by manscape
the global brand for men's grooming and
hygiene now i legitimately use manscaped
on a new daily basis because i'm a
pretty hairy dude man and i need
something to keep my gear in order so
manscape hooked me up with the
performance package 4.0 so that my
package will also be able to perform
first up is the lawnmower 4.0 body
trimmer which is waterproof with
advanced skin safe technology safety
being a pretty paramount concern when
you take sharp things and put them on
your dick also included in this package
is the crop preserver bowl deodorant and
the crop reviver ball toner and rather
appropriately just like balls they come
in a pair plus there's the weed whacker
to deal with that pesky nose and ear
hair and for a limited time you can get
all of this plus two free gifts which
are the cleverly named shed travel bag
and the manscaped anti-chafing boxer
briefs because it's not good enough to
simply do the weeding you've also got to
protect and maintain like uh like a very
sweaty vegetable garden go to
manscape.com today and get 20 off plus
free international shipping plus two
free gifts when you use my promo code
new world at checkout but for now it's
back to you me but before that how does
one go about becoming the most evil
entity in all of hunter hunter well gyro
has a pretty painfully detailed
backstory which all begins in a harsh
construction camp as a young lad age of
well young gyro was said to have been
able to mix cement and lay bricks before
he could even speak a single word
although even once he did learn i
imagine the gyro probably didn't say too
much because his father was a wildly
abusive man who would viciously beat
gyro for simply breathing too loudly
provided he was sober enough to enact it
of course and there's even one
particularly tragic example of how gyro
had to learn how to sleep without making
noise so as not to activate his father's
rage and typically it's quite difficult
to control what your body is doing while
it's asleep so to say that gyro was born
into unfortunate circumstances would be
a bit of an understatement when it comes
to gyro's father the specific word used
is god this man was a god to gyro not in
any sort of benevolent worshipping sense
but more in the fear wrath of god sort
of sense now despite that there was one
teeny tiny shred of hope that kept gyro
going one instant he recalled where as a
child he was struck with a fever and his
father stayed up all night taking care
of him the one act of kindness that his
father had ever shown him however that
was just gyrus fever playing tricks on
his mind brain in reality it was his
neighbor taking care of him whilst his
father was out getting completely
hammered that is a clever but gruesome
pun by the way and then you'll see why
soon the very last straw was when jairo
was being beaten in public you know just
your standard everyday occurrence and on
that day his father saw him and walked
right past him he saw gyro he clocked
that it was his son and he simply didn't
care now the exact quote in the manga is
at that moment everything became clear
to him the universe could care less
about his existence his father didn't
care whether he lived or died if he
lived he'd bring in money if he died
then he'd have the room to himself
that's all i was not a person i was
nobody at all this here is the moment in
virus viral this here is the moment in
gyro's supervillain origin story where
he cast aside his humanity mostly due to
the realization that he had never been
treated like a human anyway it's all
very existential almost cosmic
horror-esque with gyro realizing just
how small and insignificant he is in the
grand scheme of the universe but with
that realization came a second and this
would go on to define gyro his father
was no god this alcoholic bungle nut was
every bit as much of an oxygen thief as
jira was so giro immediately went home
and mercilessly murdered his father by
beating him to death with a hammer which
is of course the gruesome pun i was
referring to because jairo's father
spent all of his time getting hermit
anyway so this this is nothing new but
gyro promptly fled the camp vanished for
nine years and then emerged to start the
nation of ngl where he was installed as
a king but notably this is of course the
site of the original chimera ant
outbreak we'll get to that soon though
because i don't want to skip over this
whole nation building thing because
that's pretty huge and gyro's flashback
doesn't even come close to covering his
insane talents in the manga it is said
that gyro was in no hurry he knew
preparations were necessary for major
undertakings his experience in
construction made him rational and
productive so the fact that he
understood the logistics of construction
before he even knew how to say the word
construction has bred this unparalleled
planning genius within the hunt hunter
fanbase gyro was often credited as i've
said one of the most evil driven and
powersome figures but what he almost
never gets credit for is that he's also
one of the smartest which adds this
whole new tier to our sinister problem
cake gyro's goal in founding this
kingdom was quite blatantly to
disseminate evil throughout the whole
world and he did this by using the
nation to develop a certain drug known
as didi although its exact effects
remain quite vague mostly because ngl
had a little bit of a chimera ant top
break and they slaughtered everyone
including gyro before this plan could
come to fruition which you know what
that's good news right quite literally
the most evil character in the series is
dead and we never have to worry about
him again hooray well no not hooray
because this actually made matters
significantly worse the scary thing
about gyro is that he is identified as
the most driven character in the series
not by fans but by the narrator and when
a series has a power system that
directly responds to drive and desire
then if one gyro was to learn about said
power system he would naturally become
the most powerful nen user potentially
to have ever lived so if he was to be
eaten by a certain queen and reborn as
some sort of anti-nan user then that
that would be a problem sadly that's
what happened but this takes us to the
anime interpretation of events gyro was
introduced as the king of ngl but he was
already dead by the time he was
introduced and in my opinion the anime
makes an attempt to strongly suggest
that gyro after being consumed by the
ant queen was reborn as the ant king
marowan and i absolutely do not blame
any anime watchers who landed on this
conclusion because the way the 2011
series presents it makes a ton of sense
like i just said if someone is driven as
gyro were to learn nen then he would
naturally become the most powerful aura
user in all of the histories in such a
short degree of time which is exactly
what mirom did in only 40 days of
existence he eclipsed all known end
users and became the closest thing we've
seen to a literal god in hunter hunter
all knowing all powerful but with one
weakness to a certain gungi champion
plus what we know of gyro is that he is
so persistent in his belief that he is a
king just like marowan so it matches up
almost almost too perfectly and it would
actually be a really great way to bring
the chimera antarc full circle however
then right at the last second the anime
throws a pretty serious curveball
towards the end of the series we are
given a glimpse of a man in a thick coat
walking to wherever it is that men in
thick codes walk to and there is no clue
as to who or what he's doing but this
this is a reference to all of the
information that was left out of the
anime in the manga gyro was introduced
in a completely different place oh and
actually fun fact the chapter he was
introduced in being 203 appropriately
called gyro featured layorio and
karapika as the cover spread saying
when's our turn and the answer to that
would be
well not for a long long time that
chapter actually came out in 2004 and
those two would not be relevant again
for another seven years but back to evil
business gero actually comes dangerously
close to meeting with gon and killua in
the manga as all three of them happen to
be in the same city whilst gon and
kilauea are facing off against knuckle
and chute and in the manga gyro's
flashback occurs here whereas in the
anime it had already happened ages ago
when gone and killua and kite raided the
drug factory and as gyro is walking
intently through the city the narrator
says this out of the countless soldier
ants born one had an independent will
adamantly rejecting the queen's commands
his name was gyro the ngl kingpin his
malevolence and determination were
second to none and he was in the same
town as a gone and killua so gyro is the
only antecide from the king and the
royal guard who was able to ignore the
queen he just like popped out went see
ya because in his immense pride he still
considered himself to be a king plus in
gyro's brand new anti-eyes everyone and
everything was equally as irrelevant in
the grand scheme of the universe
remember he once thought of his father
as a god and after killing a god what is
there to fear from a mere ant queen now
thanks to either fate or circumstance or
both gon and gyro did not run into each
other on that particular day whether
that's a good thing or a bad thing
that's very much left up in the air
because the narrator then utters
probably the single most intriguing line
in all of hunter hunter gyro left the
town and disappeared without
encountering gone whether this proved to
be fortunate for either party will not
be known until they ultimately meet now
that that's wow because it is so
incredibly rare that togashi does
something like this he's generally a bit
of an improvised writer going arc by r
can not want to set up meta stories in
the background but on this occasion we
have confirmation that gon and gyro will
meet at some point in the series
continuity and given that gyro is the
worst case scenario for all aspects of a
pun intended antagonist it seems that
gyro is the true end game of hunter
hunter even beyond the dark continent
because sure we can go there and
experience the vast horrors of the
outside world but it is still not going
to match what this one man is capable of
and actually i should stop referring to
him as a man because mentally gyro cast
away his humanity as a child and after
physically being reborn as a chimera
aunt there is nothing human left about
gyra nor is he an ant mind you he's
something else entirely just this unique
and twisted existence after the
conclusion of the chimera antarctic
welfare posited that jaira was almost
certainly headed for meteor city in
order to commence his plans once more
and wolfen was determined to find his
old leader not to stop him but because
wealthin has faith in gyro as do all of
his former henchmen like kikalgo for
example they all believe that gyro is
some sort of savior and it's a very very
weird dynamic because while finn and
dicalgo are at heart pretty good dudes
very sympathetic characters which says
to me that gyro has been able to shroud
his true nature from them and this is a
scary thought because welfan is now an
end user so even if gyro doesn't awaken
the art form on his own the very first
thing that welfin is going to do is
teach him how to harness aura and meteor
city could not be a better location for
gyro that is it could not be a worse
location for everyone else and gyro
himself doesn't realize just how perfect
this is because right now meteor city is
completely unprotected because the
meteor city elder is dead and the
phantom troop are all headed to the dark
continent so there is no one to stop
gyro from having his way with this city
and a much more bigger issue is that the
bulk of the hunter association are also
on the dark continent mission so there
is no one to step in and quell this
threat before it gets out of hand like
the extermination team were barely able
to do with the chimera ants no one
except gone allegedly gone and gyro are
inverse characters which means what is
true for one is false of the other for
example gone grew up in a lake of
happiness whereas gyro grew up in a
puddle of misery but gyro's father was
present in his life whereas gone's
father abandoned him however gone's
journey then began to find his father
whereas gyro's journey began to get rid
of his father quite violently and whilst
we simply don't know enough about gyro
to build deeper insight it would
certainly appear that togashi was
setting him up to be an ultimate
antithesis of gone particularly because
gone also had his snap moment where he
felt that nothing mattered everything
was pointless and he was ready to throw
it all away but gone came back from that
i mean not because of anything that he
did but because of his best friend and
best boy killer however if there's
anyone in this world who can identify
with the darkness consuming gyro and the
descent from humanity into a general
monster hood then it is definitely gone
and this is a situation where the
narrator's saying that they will meet
doesn't necessarily mean that they'll
fight gon still unable to use nen might
actually be able to save the world
without using a single drop of aura but
fortunately or unfortunately he's the
only chance we have the great powers of
this series have almost universally
abandoned the human realm in pursuit of
the dark continent they don't realize it
but they've left the remainder of
humanity completely defenseless against
the greatest threat that this world has
ever faced and it's entirely possible
that if anyone does return from the dark
continent that there will be nothing
left to return to